[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español la epidemia de lakovic que
cual fantasma recorre el mundo ha dejado
tras de sí una estela de millones de
personas contaminadas cientos de miles
de muertos y sobre todo una serie de
víctimas dadas las contaminaciones que
esto ha provocado entre otros niños y
adolescentes que se encuentran entre los
primeros afectados por esta pandemia
para hablar de ello de sus consecuencias
de qué soluciones se pueden encontrar de
las experiencias que hay a este respecto
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio
amarillos moro psiquiatra infantil
autora y una serie de libros en la
materia que se pueden encontrar en
inglés francés y español y doctora
también en este tema en el hospital son
de parís mariscos moro bienvenida a este
escala en parís
muchas gracias pero gracias por
acompañarnos manejos nuevo la pandemia
de lakovic que asola al mundo decíamos
desde hace ya más de un año ha provocado
una crisis de múltiples facetas
económica social sanitaria
pero dentro de todo esto ha afectado
particularmente a ese sector de la
humanidad niños y jóvenes que de repente
se han encontrado frente a un vacío si
hemos tardado me parece a mí a reconocer
los efectos de la pandemia sobre los
niños y los adolescentes se acuerdan que
al principio se dijo que los niños que
contaminaban que cosas así en que no
eran verdad pero no tardemos en darnos
cuenta a los efectos y más que nada los
efectos psicológicos de la pandemia
vamos a verlos y también de los medios
que de que hemos utilizado para para no
paralizar para luchar contra la pandemia
y pero ahora ya sabemos que estos
efectos son muy importantes entonces se
pueden reconocer en función de las
edades no primero los bebés
hay que saber que los pequeñitos de 0 a
3 años sufren bastante de la pandemia
porque primero porque
las condiciones de sus padres el parto
el embarazo el parto y después los meses
de primeros días mil días como se dice
que son los muy importantes de estos
bebés pues los padres están en
condiciones malas no en dificultades
están las madres están muy solas
sin poder tener bastante ayuda no y
entonces estos bebés
han tenido muchos trastornos trastornos
depresivos trastornos de ansiedad y las
madres han tenido han sufrido han
padecido de mucho depresión del posparto
eso en el mundo entero e pero como si
parecía que había cosas más importantes
entonces no las hemos vistos se sucesivo
mucho por eso para los bebés después
vienen los niños de la edad escolar
estos niños usted se acuerda que en
muchos sitios en el mundo las escuelas
cerraron pero lo que quiero decir es que
en la vida de esos niños cambio en la
casa y cambio afuera de la casa y estos
niños más que nada los que han tenido
son trastornos de ansiedad es decir
manera de expresar con el cuerpo su
angustia su dificultad y también los
efectos de los duelos porque han perdido
abuelos y el miedo del exterior 90
rompen este propósito usted siguió
recibiendo niños durante la ola de la
pandemia la parte más aguda de esta
pandemia aquí en francia notablemente
justamente que dm 12 ejemplos de lo que
usted pudo ver de estos jóvenes que le
consultaron niños que usted consultó qué
es lo que resaltaban ellos
si le voy a dar un ejemplo de niño y un
ejemplo de adolescente nosotros seguimos
haciendo consultas durante todo el
tiempo
al inicio de la pandemia lo hicimos por
teléfono y por vicio pero
teleconferencias no pero muy pronto
inter e hicimos que los niños y los
adolescentes vinieran a la misión sola
en la casa de los adolescentes por eso
al hospital cosa en parís primero por
ejemplo me acuerdo de una niña que
consulto para el mes de marzo pues esa
niña tenía 10 años entonces ya no tenía
escuela desde hace más de un mes y sus
padres a mí me habían explicado mucho
que el exterior había que no se podía
salir que era como una guerra que había
un bueno todo todo esas esos
miedos que se dice a los niños para que
ellos cambien su comportamiento y
acepten de estar en la casa de no salir
y eso entonces la niña como si fuera
demasiado escrito escucho demasiado no
entonces ella empezó a desarrollar
como un miedo del exterior entonces esa
niña empezó a decir que nadie podía
salir si claro el padre tenía que salir
en algunos momentos la madre tiene que
no se ponía a llorar a dar gritos en el
test y probó mismos y si tú sales te vas
a morir no me lo has dicho entonces tú
no puedes seguir
empezó a ser tiránica no y empezó a
tener muchos dolores en el cuerpo por
todo el cuerpo no entonces llegó un
momento que sus padres llamaron porque
le fue índice bueno no sé no sé si es el
comido otra cosa pero esta niña tiene
como miedo y en realidad era transtornos
que nosotros llamamos fóbicos es decir
que el exterior da miedo no este es el
primer ejemplo al otro son los
adolescentes que los adolescentes han
tenido muchas seguramente en las
diferentes edades los camps han decidido
más y que padecen más son los
adolescentes y esos adolescentes
empezaron por tener trastornos de
ansiedad
muy pronto depresión y ganas de morir no
entonces
lo que a mí me tocó más fue por ejemplo
un niño de 16 años y medio que él vivía
bien con sus padres sus hermanos sus
amigos y eso
su abuelo murió en el hospital de kobe
no y aparte y el bueno estaba en la casa
muy poco salir muy poco ver no ver a sus
amigos ambos no podía ayudar al deporte
ya no podía hacer nada al externo
entonces empezó a desarrollar la idea
que bueno papá que vivir no que
significa para mí vivir esa precocidad
me cortó esas preguntas de los
adolescentes y entonces sé cómo se dejó
morir no dice estaba en la habitación ya
no quería salir no quería comer no
quería hablar a sus amigos no quería
escuchar música con sus amigos por
teléfono o por por esos medios de
comunicaciones que tenemos durante esta
pandemia que nos ayuda a tener
relaciones él había perdido al gusto de
la relación con el mundo exterior y esto
hay que decir que hoy tenemos en francia
pero en toda europa y las cifras son
casi igual de las que tenemos en el
mundo casi todas las mismas
tenemos entre 20 y 40 por ciento de
aumentación entiendo
la función de las edades de demandas de
consultas es muchísimo manejo estamos
claro hablando de un país que tiene los
medios para atender a una buena parte de
la población hay una parte que se queda
afuera selection bed pero bueno al menos
existe esta posibilidad usted ha tenido
oportunidad también de estar en méxico
en argentina en colombia en países de
américa latina donde esos medios son
mucho más restringidos mucho más
limitados hay gente que dice por ejemplo
en el caso de argentina que es el país
que más ha confinado en el mundo más de
un año donde los jóvenes estuvieron
fuera de las escuelas hay gente que
empieza a ir estamos frente a una
generación perdida es válido este tipo
de argumento piensa usted
he hecho muchas intercambios y
conferencias con argentina porque tengo
muchas relaciones cuando de argentina
por ejemplo durante la pandemia y yo no
estoy de acuerdo aunque ese es verdad
hay muchas en francia en europa ya sin
igualdades y mismo para poder tener
consultas y yo sé que en latinoamérica
en todos los países que ha dicho usted
es todavía más difícil y hay más
diferencias y más dificultades pero no
se puede decir que la generación que
está en el comité es una generación
hasta que sea crucificada no porque
sería decir como se dice en francés dos
una pena doble no es decir si han tenido
muchas muchas dificultades si es verdad
que lo más que hoy es mañana es decir
como esos jóvenes se representan el
mundo de mañana su función su papel en
el mundo
la capacidad para ellos de actuar y de
cambiar el mundo es verdad que todo eso
es un poco difícil para ellos pero decir
que son sacrificado es decir que que ya
no hay nada que hacer eso no corresponde
ni a la realidad de los niños que y de
los adolescentes que muchos de ellos
mismos los que las historias que yo le
contaba antes de este por ejemplo esta
adolescente que perdió
el deseo de salir y el deseo de vivir
pues sólo el el lo vuelve a encontrar
bueno eso él tuvo la posibilidad de
hablar con un psicoterapeuta durante
unos bueno unas semanas más que nada
y eso le hizo mucho bien pero yo he
visto muchos adolescentes encontrar
modalidad de salir de eso no se puede
decir eso porque sería nuestra visión
nosotros los adultos del mundo y es
quitarle todavía la posibilidad de ellos
de resiliencia de conjuntamente de
competencia hay esta palabra privacidad
la saca usted de la lengua la
resiliencia es de la posibilidad de
adaptarse e ir avanzando aquí en francia
por ejemplo empezamos a una especie de
vuelta a la normalidad pero que no están
viendo a futuro se empiezan a abrir las
escuelas con ciertos límites el trabajo
colectivo el hecho de volver a la
colectividad a volver a la ver a la
gente esto puede servir una especie de
trampolín eventualmente para que estos
jóvenes que han pasado por una periodo
muy complicado es una generación muy
formada pero al mismo tiempo se le dice
no debe de salir lo que estemos
comentando un primer momento esto podría
permitir que superen este traumatismo
positivo claro esto es muy importante el
hecho de salir y de volver a encontrar
sus posibilidades de
de relaciones de comunicaciones de
interacciones eso es lo fundamental para
los niños y los adolescentes pero hay
que tenemos que tener cuidado de no hace
la misma
el mismo error que hicimos durante la
crisis ahora en esta en este momento de
la postcrisis crisis porque al nivel
psicológico los efectos de lo que hemos
vivido que son como ejemplos igual los
efectos de una guerra en otras
situaciones después al nivel psicológico
son todavía más importantes después
porque al momento que ya el peligro
exterior ya no es tan fuerte se puede
decir tengo miedo no estoy bien no tengo
ganas de más todavía que antes porque
antes había que sobrevivir y ahí después
estamos en una situación no sólo de
sobrevivir sino de inventar una nueva
manera de vivir porque esta crisis no es
un año y medio después pasamos a otra
cosa no es algo que va a tener efectos y
que yo creo que va a permitir a la nueva
generación de detenerlo fuerza y detener
la invencibilidad pero pero hay que
ayudarles hay que ayudarles hay que
tener confianza en ellos lamentablemente
el tiempo se nos va se va muy rápido
amarillos mogo yo quiero agradecerles su
presencia aquí yo recuerdo que ustedes
siquiera
de niños y adolescentes que trabaja en
el hospital colchón que tiene una amplia
bibliografía que les recomiendo la
consulte a propósito de este mundo de
los niños y adolescentes y de cómo han
sido afectados por lakovic gracias por
haber estado en este escala en parís
gracias a ustedes les damos una nueva
cita en otra escala en parís la próxima
semana
[Música]
e